هنا في دبي ، افتتحت تأشيرة الدخول مؤخرًا
مقرها الإقليمي الذي يخدم 90
سوقًا وفي قلب كل ذلك
مركز الابتكار الرائع الذي يتمتع
بتكنولوجيا مذهلة لديها
القدرة
على تغيير حياتنا ومن
ثم جعل التسوق أسهل كثيرًا
ولكن مركز الابتكار هذا  لا
يتعلق الأمر
بالتسوق فقط ، هذا هو مركز الابتكار
حقًا حيث يحدث السحر ، لذا فإن
ما ستمر به الآن هو
منطقة تجربة مبنية مع
مراعاة رحلة المستخدمين النهائيين ، يرأس أكشاي شوبرا
مركز الابتكار في Visa
الإقليمية التي افتتحت حديثًا  المقر الرئيسي في
دبي ، أنا أشغل مقعدًا ، هذا أنا ،
هذا كل شيء لك للغاية ، حيث أشرف على 90
سوقًا من أوروبا إلى آسيا ، يمكنك أن تأخذ
أي سطح مثل محطة للحافلات ومحطة مترو
، وتحولها إلى
متجر تجزئة مجهز جيدًا ودعنا نقول فقط إنه
من الرائع
تحويل الكرات والأعمال المنزلية اليومية
إلى متعة رقمية ،
هذا في الواقع أول شيء جيد حقًا ،
ألا تعتقد أنه يضيف إلى عربة التسوق
الرائعة  نريد أن نجعل من السهل على
الناس أن يدفعوا أجورهم ، فنحن نعمل مع
الحكومات مع شركات التكنولوجيا المالية مع البنوك
مع التجار من جميع الأشكال والأحجام
للمساعدة في بناء تجارب
دفع أكثر ملاءمة وأكثر سلاسة وأمانًا
في منطقة حيث يقول كاسيوس كينج أكشاي
أدى الوباء العالمي إلى تسريع
الانتقال إلى النظام الرقمي في الواقع ،
لقد قام الوباء بعمل هائل
في تغيير تصورات الناس
حول
المدفوعات الرقمية إذا نظرت إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ،
رأينا 94 من مدفوعاتنا ، هناك عدم
تلامس ، وهو بشكل عام
أكثر أمانًا بالإضافة إلى كونه أكثر
نظافة وصحة.  لذا فقد غير هذا الاتجاه
المدفوعات إلى الأبد ، فقد اعتاد الناس كثيرًا
على النقر والذهاب أكثر مما
كانوا عليه من قبل
، والخطوة التالية لإدخال
الأعمال الصغيرة من الخباز إلى السوق أو
صاحب السوق ،
أريد مزيج التوابل هذا ، من فضلك هذا هو
العمود الفقري  بالنسبة للاقتصاد العالمي ولكن
للأسف الكثير من
الشركات الصغيرة غالبًا ما تُستبعد من
أحدث التقنيات الرقمية وهي كذلك
الأشخاص الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليها ، كيف
سيؤدي ذلك إلى
تغيير الصناعة هنا في الشرق الأوسط
بمجرد أن تبدأ العمل على نطاق أوسع
مع التجار الصغار ، وأعتقد أن ذلك
سيؤدي إلى رقمنة الاقتصاد إلى
حد أكبر بكثير مما لدينا الآن
وأعتقد  أن إدخال هؤلاء الأشخاص
في الاقتصاد سيجعل الاقتصاد الرقمي الرسمي
منهم أكثر إنتاجية
وأكثر كفاءة وسيجعل
النظام بأكمله أكثر شفافية
المدفوعات الرقمية عالية التقنية
والقياسات الحيوية التي تغير الطريقة التي نؤدي بها
أعمالنا ومستقبل التمويل و
يمر عبر هذه
الأشياء الرائعة الرائعة الرائعة في انتظار تسليم الطائرة بدون طيار